un petit village en plein coeur des
vosges ici pas de garni de supermarchés
encore moins de discothèque le coin n'a
rien de touristique et pourtant c'est
ici qu'un drôle d'hurluberlus a eu
l'idée de créer un camping un camping
al'allure de son propriétaire
atypique denis n'a pas le brevet de
pilote
de toute façon son avion n'a aucune
chance de décoller sa caravelle denis
l'a métamorphosé en un mobile home
unique au monde ici vous avez espace
chambre où là vous avez des convertibles
donc qui peuvent permettre de faire ou
sully et si la cabine douche qui aménagé
dans un espace qui était réservé aux
hôtesses ici-bas vous avez les toilette
wc et puis la labour c'est cinq fois
plus cher que de louer une tente
traditionnelle
alors là ça tout petit plus de ce plus
de 100 euros en fait c'est 110 euros
parce que ici vous avez quand même une
suite 80 mètres carrés denis a racheté
cet avion de ligne pour un franc
symbolique à une grande compagnie
aérienne qui voulait s'en débarrasser
alors sur le poste de pilotage reste
plus grand chose aujourd'hui il la
démonter entièrement est remonté pièce
par pièce dans son village natal
ça lui a pris sept ans
mais son camping était lancée désormais
tous les week-ends il fait le plein
aventure à ses clients des couples et
des familles prêt à payer 100 euros pour
dormir dans des endroits insolites du
froid de preixan moment et passait la
nuit à même la paille dans les arbres
sous une yourte ou encore plus
surprenant sous cet igloo transparente
et kaman on voit rien la cardine on peut
profiter des efforts tentés de rêver en
même temps c'est sympa avec ses
logements bizarroïde denis réalise plus
de deux cent mille euros de chiffre
d'affaires par an il a compris que les
gens sont prêts à payer le prix fort
même pour camper
jugé ringard il ya encore peu le camping
redevient tendance cette année nous
serons plus de 9 millions à planter la
tente un mode de vacances économique qui
attire aujourd'hui un nouveau style de
campeurs la clientèle haut de gamme des
touristes exigeant qui tiennent à leur
confort et qui en plus veulent s'amuser
pendant leurs vacances
du coup les propriétaires de terrains
investissent des sommes colossales pour
se moderniser transformer leurs villages
de toile en vrai petit parc
d'attractions
petite virée dans ces campings qui
veulent vous redonner envie de dormir en
plein air dans les régions très
touristiques les campings qu'on n'arrive
même plus à les compter tellement il y
en a c'est le cas d'hourtin sur la côte
atlantique
une petite ville balnéaire où les
enseignes s'enchaînent à perte de vue
mais au beau milieu de ce marché est
complètement saturé il y en un qui
détonne une fois le portail franchi on
se croit revenu au bon vieux temps de la
conquête de l'ouest des bâtiments comme
à l'époque du far west des tipis indiens
un ranch et des vacanciers qui jouent
aux cow boys et aux indiens
l'homme qui a eu l'idée de monter ce
village western c'est arnaud pérou à
l'origine une catastrophe naturelle
en 1999 son établissement un camping
tout ce qu'il ya de plus normal et
ravagé par la tempête lothar arnaud se
retrouve avec un demi million d'euros de
dette
il décide de se mettre encore plus de
crédit sur le dos pour relancer son
affaire on vient effectivement de très
loin puisqu'on était donné perdant à
100% par par tout le monde
j'ai eu des propositions de rachat des
gens qui m'ont dit surtout faut que tu
arrêtes parce que tu t'en sortiras pas
c'est de là qu'est né le concept du
village western le rapport aux pionniers
celui qui par l'esprit la connaissance
et le courage arrive à se développer à
survivre à n'importe quelle situation
arnaud n'a jamais mis les pieds en
amérique c'est dans les livres et au
cinéma qu'il est allé chercher toutes
ces idées comme ce bâtiment aux faux
airs de petite maison dans la prairie
cette façade a été récupérée sur une
photographie que j'avais d'une école de
pennsylvanie 1881
coût des travaux trois cent mille euros
mais il faut dire que c'est une
installation indispensable à un camping
bienvenue dans les tous premiers
sanitaire western
donc là on a les découvreurs comme cole
ont évidemment des lic roquettes qui ont
exploré le territoire en long en large
et en travers
donc du coup les présidents
et puis après les généraux de la guerre
de sécession si arnaud a mis autant
d'argent c'est parce que c'est le genre
d'endroit où on peut passer beaucoup de
temps
sacrilège dessus des latrines
mais à la limite pourquoi
quel est le meilleur endroit où vous
passez du temps sans rien avoir à faire
mais des décors aussi beau soit-il ça ne
suffit pas pour ramener du monde
il faut aussi proposer des animations
ici aucun risque de tomber sur une
élection miss camping ou un tournoi de
pétanque
même la télévision est interdite arnaud
a imaginé des activités inspirées de
western à la place ce matin dans la
petite rivière qui l'a fabriqué lui même
c'est la ruée vers l'or bug qui faisait
ça toute la journée pour pouvoir manger
et ça ne désemplit jamais arnaud a
dispersé dans l'eau des paillettes d'or
des vrais et chacun peut repartir avec
celle qu'il a trouvé elles sont
minuscules voir microscopiques mais l'or
ça fait toujours rêver
3 payet une deux et trois c'est le début
de la région c'est une bonne année
il y a aussi des cours de l'assaut et
même une leçon sur les armes à feu
utilisées par les pionniers de l'ouest
calibre 44
c'est le modèle arnaud est intarissable
sur le sujet c'est un revolver parce
qu'il faut que je rigole
à chaque fois que je vais tirer j'aurais
armes alors attention et les enfants
fascinés
on est loin du film camping chaud
marrons qui est drôle mais on est loin
de ce film on n'est pas un camping entre
guillemets beau pour nana on est
indépendants on n'est pas les uns sur
les autres
je pense que c'est vraiment un camping
d'avenir ça me réconcilie être au
complet prêt esteban quatre ans et demi
n'est pas prêt d'oublier son séjour
alors le plus étonnant c'est que
personne ne sort son porte-monnaie pour
participer à tous ces ateliers des
animations payantes c'est toujours
pénible on hésite à y participer parce
qu'à chaque fois que je rajoute
caractère ajouté rajouter là ce système
permet au moins d'avoir des personnes
qui arrivent et que sourire parce que du
coup entre nous il ne se passe que un
échange d'informations et d'idées
il n'y a pas de notion d'argent entre
nous si les clients n'ont pas
l'impression de payer il ne s'agit que
d'une impression en réalité arnaud
répercutent le coût de ces activités un
peu plus de 1000 euros sur l'ensemble de
ces locations je préfère faire en sorte
que chacun paye 10 centimes sur
l'ensemble de son séjour
enfin par jour pour l'animation dont
tout le monde paye en fête animations
pour que chacun à chaque fois n'est pas
à mettre la main au porte monnaie
tout le monde paye pour l'activité est
ce qu'ils veulent ils participent au
final cette petite augmentation que
personne ne remarque lui rapporte 5000
euros de bénéfices par an mais
l'attraction star de son camping celle
qui fait venir le plus de monde c'est
les chevaux jetterait si grenier de
skarlet kenshi à esbarres nous avons 37
chevaux
c'est la seule attraction payante mais
elle a permis à arnaud d'attirer ici des
campeurs plutôt inattendue
comme jackie et sa bande de copains qui
d'habitude préfère chevauchée leur
harley davidson
ils ont même fait de ce camping le qg de
leur rassemblement
chaque fois qu'on ya aucun
automatiquement vie dossiers sont bien
les bikers sont attirés par le style
américain c'est bien connu
voilà un biker contrairement à ce que
certains france on adore la nature et on
aime bien les animaux
voilà et qu'il avait et l'amérique le
sol américain s'ils sont copains félix
nord mène pas large peut faire sur ma
moto je mange mal le sens pau avec un
cheval là mais le nombre de femmes et 14
euros
jacky lui a l'air d'un vrai cowboy
ils piaffent il est pressé chante on va
s'entendre tous les voeux sauf que
vouloir monter un cheval attaché c'est
un peu comme rouler avec le cadenas
accroché à la roue de sart les accrocher
les crochets là s'il vous plaît
finalement plus de peur que de mal
un bakker ne se laisse pas désarçonner
si facilement
ces petites promenades rapporte 60000
euros à son camping tous les étés
ça paraît beaucoup mais c'est loin de
lui rembourser tous les frais
occasionnés par les chevaux arnaud faire
de l'argent avec ses chevaux ce n'est
pas grave il s'agit d'un produit d'appel
pour que ses clients viennent dormir
chez lui
et le type de logement qui rapporte le
plus ce sont les mobil homes ces
caravanes qui ressemblent à des petites
maisons
arnaud en a déjà à 92 pour cet été il en
a commandé une vingtaine de plus
aujourd'hui il réceptionne les derniers
plaçant tout neuf et ils viennent juste
de sortir de l' usine de lézignan sur ce
camion il y en a pour 35000 euros
enfin beaucoup c'est déjà pas mal pour
deux mobile homes après il ya les frais
de calage les frais de terrasses
il ya donc tout un tas de frais
afférents d'aménagement de parcelles qui
font que et bien la valeur mobile home à
l'achat pour la x 2 grosso modo par
rapport à l'aménagement sur le terrain à
ce prix là arnoux compte sur une qualité
irréprochable
alors avant de signer le bon de
livraison il s'assure qu'il n'y a pas de
problème les mobil homes sont de plus en
plus large et les routes ont toujours la
même taille les arbres sont pas
forcément très bien taillée par la dde
ce qui fait qu'il ya toujours des
endroits où ça frotte les gouttières
priori c'est la tienne le chapeau n'est
pas tordue donc la cheminée n'a pas été
touchée mais auriez pas eu de problème
là il a été shootée ok je vais dire que
pour le va dire que pour le châssis 672
je pouvais signer la feuille de route
est sans merci
ce qu'il ya de bien avec un mobile home
away pas trop là c'est bon c'est qu'il
est très rapide installé il suffit de le
mettre en place de raccorder l'eau le
gaz et l'électricité
dès le lendemain il est prêt à être
loués
mais surtout son gros avantage il est
extrêmement rentable
les clients sont prêts à payer jusqu'à
1200 euros la semaine
car à l'intérieur il y a tout le confort
moderne
jean est serré c'est les frigos congèle
c'est le convecteur dans chaque pièce
c'est de l'éclairage led alors suite
parentale sur ce type de mobile homes
c'est quand même vachement bien des
placards et surtout dans la chambre dans
la chambre la salle de bain il y a aussi
une salle à manger
deux autres chambres pour les enfants et
même un second cabinet toilettes sans
oublier la vue imprenable sur la
campagne
ici comme ailleurs les mobil homes
remplace petit à petit les emplacements
réservés aux tentes et ce n'est pas
uniquement pour faire plaisir aux
clients ce et les mobile homes qui
rapporte le plus d'argent mais tentant
rapporte de moins en moins en proportion
malgré le malgré le volume
d'emplacements c'est simple c'est clair
un emplacement de camping avec sa valeur
au quotidien une personne qui qui va
devoir payer je sais pas moi 50 euros
par jour pour une famille de quatre
personnes avec électricité on est loin
effectivement des 100 ou 120 euros la
nuitée du mobil-home des mobile homes
tout confort une ambiance cow boy plein
d'activités avec sa formule arnaud
affiche complet pour la saison
saleh fini tu pourrais nous montrer les
plannings cet été ça te plaît alors
voilà ce qui est prévu pour juillet août
et début septembre
donc ce qu'on appelle la haute saison
vous voyez tout ce qui est rouge c'est
ce qui est occupée par tous vous avez du
blanc c'est libre je dirais d'une
certaine manière plus que ça c'est c'est
obligatoire parce que si jamais on
n'était pas certain d'avoir on va dire
ce type de remplissage au regard des
investissements que l'on fait ça
pourrait devenir très rapidement
dangereux
la plus grande difficulté pour nous
c'est de se dire voilà il ne faut pas
rater cette période là c'est là où nous
allons faire 90 % du chiffre d'affaires
de l'année
arnaud devrait approcher le million
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires cette
année
à l'avenir il espère même gagner
beaucoup plus et pour ça il veut faire
de son camping l'un des plus beaux de
france
alors pour en mettre plein la vue à ses
clients il est en train de reconstituer
leurs pairs des cowboys un saloon à
250000 euros sur un grand bar qui va
retourner donc ici qui va faire là car
tournant comme ça donc tout le plancher
sera un plancher chaîne après on a un
papier très très rouge sur le mur avec
de grande corniche en bois sculpté avec
un escalier qui montre plus que dans
tout les saloons y avait forcément
l'escalier qui monte à l'étagé pour les
pour les prendre quelques plaisirs
arnaud vise la clientèle qui fait rêver
tous les propriétaires de camping des
vacanciers à fort pouvoir d'achat et qui
ne viennent que dans des hébergements
haut de gamme des établissements classés
cinq étoiles comme les hôtels et pour
obtenir cette distinction le camping
doit se soumettre à un examen où il doit
décrocher la mention très bien
ce matin michel chazottes a rendez-vous
dans les environs de rodez dans
l'aveyron un camping a demandé à passer
en cinq étoiles et c'est lui qui va
devoir trancher vient de démarrer
c'est le premier de cette cette semaine
qui arrive
michel est à la tête des toiles de
france une petite entreprise
d'inspection son boulot vérifier que les
installations des campings correspondent
bien aux exigences de la catégorie
demandé à chanter le propriétaire s'est
lui martin cinglant et il a tout intérêt
à ce que le contrôle se passe bien
son camping fait partie d'un groupe qui
lui impose de passer de 3 à 5 étoiles
c'est pour cette raison qu'il est aussi
inquiet quand michel pose ses premières
questions sur votre site internet
sauf erreur de ma part je n'ai pas vu
l'accessibilité handicapés et pourtant
michel n'arrive pas à l'improviste
c'est le propriétaire lui même qui l'a
contacté et le rémunère pour cette
évaluation entre 500 et 2000 euros selon
la taille de l'établissement d'accords
l'espace mais michel jeu n'a pas
l'intention de faire de cadeaux à son
client
et j'ai également vu que vous aviez une
réservation numérique en ligne
est ce que par exemple je pourrais voir
les gens qui ont réservé pour ce soir
via internet s'il vous plaît ce soir
aucune réservation vous avez pas par
exemple monsieur dolisie qui vous aurait
réservé pour contrôler si beaucoup
si michel a le sourire aux lèvres c'est
parce que ce fameux dolisie c'est lui
tout simplement il n'a pas hésité à
piéger le camping visiblement ça la muse
la ration problème je lui ai envoyé par
mail via votre site
personne n'a vu cette réservation voilà
c'est cela dont vous pouvez l'annuler
pour ce soir merci ça commence plutôt
mal et ce n'est pas terminé
michel à près de 200 points à contrôler
le camping est installé dans un
environnement magnifique
le vertdure mais curieusement le cadre
bucolique michel n'en a rien à faire ça
n'entre pas dans les critères d'un cinq
étoiles lui ce qui l'intéresse c'est
l'espace alouettes ici à chaque mobile
honneur bien mais on va installer tout
ça nous avons une exigence des 80 m²
minimum pour la catégorie 5 étoiles
nous sommes là pour bien vérifier que le
l'exploitant propose bien aux minimes à
4 mètres carrés nous assurons 70 49 et
600 mètres carrés
enfin un bon point pour les emplacements
inconfortable c'est vaste couverture
internet partout tri sélectif accès au
camping michele valley tranquillement
tout ce qui est demandé aux cinq étoiles
il nous reste là bas autour de la
piscine maintenant thalys le toboggan
pour garder les tailles la propreté une
nouvelle fois de l'espace aquatique voir
s'il ya pas de des margelles la mauvais
état kas est dangereuse et ça sans
mettre un pied dans la zone des bassins
la qualité de l'eau où la température là
aussi ça n'entre pas en compte
température non la presse et c'est la
clientèle qui définira savez comment ça
se passe on peut être très bien à 28°
d'autres souhaité du 35 degrés voilà
mais là tout est en place tout
fonctionne
eh bien puis on l'a vu il ya quelques
minutes les enfants dans l'eau il avait
l'air à chanter si le contrôle à la
piscine semble un peu sommaire il y à un
endroit primordial du camping sur lequel
michel sera sans pitié
c'est l'état des toilettes
sommes sur une demande en 5 étoiles donc
on attend quelque chose de parfait que
ce soit au niveau des wc ou des douches
des toilettes à la turque ça ne fait pas
vraiment luxe mais étonnamment la
réglementation l'autorisent et michel
nautique pas en revanche dans ce bloc
sanitaire ils repèrent deux détails qui
ne peut pas laisser passer les faïences
et casser ça se passe pas et pourquoi là
bas on a mis des joueurs noirs
voilà pour moi ça c'est pas acceptable
par l'omi la cinquième étoile nommée
dans le grand confort on est dans
quelque chose d'instable la nôtre le
demander c'est quasiment du 18 sur verre
donc dit c'est pas atteint ici est en
principe ces mêmes éliminatoires
le dernier bloc mais à l'heure du bilan
l'inspecteur va faire preuve de
souplesse selon lui le camping mérite sa
cinquième étoile
mon premier ressenti c'est que vous avez
une très belle exploitation
je ferai une paire d'efforts sur deux
sur deux blocs sanitaires mais avec elle
chez beaucoup de ses fans comme
assurables
non je sais pas celui qui la bonne idée
de mettre des joueurs noirs sur ces
lavabo blanc ça fait pas du tout propre
il suffit de les raclées de remettre sa
propre question voilà le directeur a
deux semaines pour changer le carrelage
et les joints très bonne saison et comme
preuve des travaux il lui suffira
d'envoyer une simple photo à michel cet
été ce camping devrait pouvoir afficher
5 étoiles sans aucun problème
si la majorité des campings veut faire
du haut de gamme c'est que cela peut
rapporter très gros
certains l'ont bien compris et ils en
ont même fait un business à grande
échelle
le petit plaisir de gilbert c'est de
dormir dans un mobile home
quand il est en déplacement
professionnel j'ai ouvert un peu la
piscine et à l'air de faire beau dans
quoi on l'a ouverte mais ce sexagénaire
n'est pas un campeur comme les autres
c'est l'homme le plus puissant du
secteur 50 établissements 45 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires chaque
année déjà les vendanges et la
tranquille un familier ouais c'est super
ça ça me plaît mais moi ça me réjouit de
voir les gens à la tranquille heureux
j'espère qu'ils aient plaisir ça fait
vite parce que c'est le but de
rechercher quoi
gilbert a racheté cet établissement très
bien située dans les landes il y a
quelques années et depuis qu'il a repris
c'est devenu une affaire florissante
le chiffre d'affaires de ce camping
quand on apprit on était amis en 4 on
doit être au double environ est au tour
de 2006 devient 8 1 4 ans oui c'est une
question d'équipement
sa recette elle est simple mais très
efficace
misez sur les familles et leur proposer
des campings 4 ou 5 étoiles où il
investi plusieurs millions d'euros dans
les loisirs l'aurait pas terrible un
couleurs comme les piscines
chez gilbert elles ont des allures de
parc aquatique cette piscine c'est
l'attrait évidemment du camping parce
que ici on a 60 cm dans ça peut faire un
bassin en femme et patauger près des
parents qui qui peuvent les surveiller
elle est à différents bassins il ya un
bassin là bas ou la nage à contre
courant qu il ya des toboggans où les
enfants évidemment se régaler de
décembre il a cinq
et il y en a un autre un petit peu plus
modèle ancien mais que funky qui marche
très bien
côté logement pas de tipis pas de
yourtes mais des mobile homes à perte de
vue
ces campings ressemblent à des villages
de vacances on est nous sur 90% de la
population qui est notre cible
la stratégie d'entreprise nous c'est de
m comment dirais-je effectivement des
mobiles ont aidé les emplacements et de
viser
le maximum de clients tête donc une
palette très large monsieur et madame
tout le monde
ça a toujours été son credo dans les
affaires et ça lui a plutôt bien réussi
ce chef d'entreprise originaire de sète
a fait fortune dans les résidences de
vacances mais à cause de la crise il a
dû diversifier son activité
il y encore six ans il ne connaissait
rien au camping aujourd'hui il est le
numéro 1 en france
bonjour dans son immeuble un étage
entier réservé à sa propre centrale de
réservation et un autre à la publicité
s'est étendu en commun de 2,44 langues
un troisième à la recherche de camping à
vendre aujourd'hui l'activité camping
occupe la quasi totalité de ses bureaux
ya cinq ans on avait zéro personne dans
le domaine de l'hôtellerie plein air
donc on a créé je virais 200 emplois en
dehors en dehors comment dirais-je des
saisonniers que nous prônons pendant
toute la saison il y a une chose que
gilbert ne se lasse pas de regarder
c'est l'étendue de son empire à chaque
acquisition une pastille l'île de ré où
là c'est un peu son monopoly à lui une
cinquantaine de camping implanté dans
toutes les régions touristiques de
france ou presque
l'ardèche j'ai pas trouvé de camping
exploités qui se vendent des eaux dans
les négociations nous avons pu avoir sur
région très prisée très prisé l'ardèche
très très prisé des clients en attendant
de conquérir l'ardèche ce patron vient
de réaliser l'un de ses plus beaux coups
et c'est ici au bord de l'atlantique il
l'a fait
c'est le pas ce matin il est à côté de
mimizan dans les landes donc au coude en
profiter trois ans qu'il était sur le
coup six mois de tractations et un
chèque de 4 millions d'euros à la clé
gilbert vient de s'offrir un fonds de
commerce unique en france
le sol est aussi parce que c'est tout à
faire c'est tout à fait ça c'est un
grand plaisir
ce n'est pas la plage qu'il s'est
offerte mais à moins de 50 mètres du
littoral
trente deux hectares de terrains des
installations complètement laissée à
l'abandon qui ont des allures de ville
fantôme
et pour cause à l'origine c'est un
village du club med fermé dans les
années 60
régalez devenir de gilbert a donné une
enveloppe de 6 millions d'euros à
l'architecte pour construire un
gigantesque camping 2 800 emplacements
où les campeurs auront tout à portée de
main c'est une ville quoi c'est une
ville complète qu'il faut gérer tente
les parties privatives comme les parties
communes donc donc ça fait beaucoup de
monde et l'animation et le cinéma et les
ateliers pour les enfants les vies des
deux clubs les spas et pour ça il ne va
pas y aller par quatre chemins il va
tout raser ce bâtiment c'est l'ancien
restaurant du club med
tout est resté figé comme dans les
années 60 comme si le temps s'était
arrêté
il est magnifique ce thé chez gilbert
tito la nostalgie ça va bien cinq
minutes alors du tout dans tout bon jeu
je le verrais bien pour un parent qui je
le sais gauche c'est un gars comme ça
peut paraître impensable mais
l'ouverture est prévue pour l'été
prochain
à terme ce camping devrait générer 5
millions d'euros de recettes par an dans
son monopoly gilbert vient de s'acheter
la rue de la paix